hello everybody back play limbo
okay we got some water here we just got
past the brainslug part and I'm gonna
try and never ever ever get stuck
because oh if I get stuck people like
rip me apart so I'm gonna be totally
awesome play using my brain and whatnot
I get stuck for two minutes on the game
I've never played before and roast me
alive my fat god
well we got how can I died hello sliding
down
it's a bouche oops oh no I'm going to
get lamb basted limb but limb bastard
lambaste lambaste
whoosh that's the attorney let me guess
that's a gutter that I can climb totally
obvious I got oh wow
panicked I panicked sorry sorry
everybody sorry I died again
gaah how can I you ever forgive me bo t
easy easy
I got it let me get the Crimean live I
touched that ha ha that's hardly fair oh
I don't go on it do i hook cut ha ha
come I didn't make anyone scream at the
computer screen and no I'm not gonna let
that go
oh oh are you screaming yet y'all angry
at me guess what I don't care up puff up
job everyone ah well what the dick there
we go
OOP Yong ha yeah you're due to go back
you'll see I'll see I figure it out fair
out a puzzle that I've never played
before
it took me less than 2 minutes this time
punched I'm good
guess what I don't care ok bunch of
doshas doucement
lucky i'm playing this game i won doc
hey whoa whoa aah
oh that arrows going down all right I
made it happy now happy at anything
bunch of jerks hit you'll so much
are you all right everyone I hate
everyone up there we go okay now that
that's over with I'm gonna go back to
enjoying the game oh okay oh oh sorry
that took me an extra second to get
sorry sorry sorry
I don't know
oh I can't figure it out I'm stuck what
am I gonna do yeah I need to jump from
the ladder obviously hope I'm gonna wait
for it to come back come on back come on
back come on I got it
wait hang on that question if I do
from up here if I do this and then I
climb up and get for it - Boosh over and
then I push and then I space nice jump
unsturdy off sorry that took me an extra
two seconds but the jerks you know I'm
talking about you know you know who you
are Paul and chill know the assassin ani
I'm not another one I know who you are
and then we sleep get you and I'm never
gonna forgive you don't don't
but in my brain why do I keep letting
this happen who put you
you know I've got probably up like a
permanent hole in my head now oh oh
that's that's not good
well maybe I got to push that before I
go over there
your bouche I bushi all right now I go
get the brain slug in my brain seriously
I must have like a giant hole in my head
by now have three of these scented did
you do part I know
okay I'll go this way
all sorry did that mean missing that
puzzle make you scream at your computer
I'm so sorry
now we go the other way what spray acid
into my brain I'm probably never going
to be normal again after this so
whatever three brain slugs into your
cerebral cortex isn't gonna do good for
you
hello is that a switch here No
hello hello anybody anybody around oh
okay still look cool I don't look good
how'd you good good oh man how long am I
gonna have this brain slug
to do to put your dad who dude
and yes the noises oh I'm not touching
that huh nope oh crap I was supposed to
touch that I was supposed to touch that
ah really is that how it is going gray
at me I don't care
yone you scream while I'm yelling back
ah
Oh bet you're angry now
oh all the rage is building oh good
slow-mo
and then I jump all you're so mad how's
that rage coming along yes
oh well not all just I'm never gonna
forgive you if you're wondering oh god
how long is this gonna go on
yeah it's never gonna end alright again
big whoops you mad yeah it's never gonna
stop so yeah you brought this on
yourself and yeah yeah I'm mad I'm mad
at you
oh and then it knows I got it I got it
there we go tada
I did it Wow okay so I wasn't
fortunately I get it
pop I did
I'm going to go back now
you know you know who you are probably
cuz I named your username I know
but get back down there
i Boosh you okay I run on you oh I'm not
going to make it
oh maybe I oh I did I did hurt otter you
I go back and forth on here I do it
again on you and then I ran on you and
then I jump with you in a chip on you
then I could on the others dataview and
then I rent to the others head of you
I'm not getting this quick enough for
you guys
sorry sorry I'm going to do it again
just for good measure
then I go back and then I go straight up
anything about it today did you get ah
come on
not fair man little bit of English yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
one more word oh no no no no I can make
that ah there we go
there we go oh sorry sorry that wasn't
good enough for you guys
OOP OOP OOP
hun get on it turn it in in an ear yeah
I'm the best I'm the best apparently not
for some people but I'm the best to me
look how good I'm with my happy jump
tanks unforgivable I don't have
unforgivable yeah yeah yeah unforgivable
unforgivable unforgivable
but no way I'm pretty wait was there
anything over there I don't think there
was anything that useful but let me
check let me waste more time let me make
these people angry out there
unforgivable
I don't think they're dead this is plus
sign or this down arrow up here whatever
you wanna call her tea house you up on
you okay there's nothing oh sorry I
wasted people's times oh I'm sorry about
that
no I'm not I'm not sorry I'm never gonna
be sorry all show yes I sign honey I'll
kill you in your sleep
but it's okay
it's okay it's okay really not okay
it's okay whatever whatever whatever no
big deal whatever where you just call me
an idiot
mm-hmm you see
okay so what's the deal here okay
all righty I'll take that I wish you a
bit abyss you a bouche you alone oh okay
do I use it like Jesus I could jump up
there anyway so my book is over here
Billy
see if that did anything maybe I don't
know what that did or what that was hard
but whatever oh good I pull you buddy
hello going oh I need the box
ah I need some else people get this box
up y'all
well how do I do that
hmm so not a box get down get down from
down get down
I don't know if it was another box and
not another box that I could get oh no
I'm getting stuck on a pleasure oh it's
so hard
Oh better better make fun of me made her
better better make insult me feelings
hurt
okay anyway um you just got to get this
box up here but how'd you do that
Hey Boosh
oh I don't push if I stand over here
so did I Boosh you okay well I guess I
got stuck forever on a puzzle oh I guess
it's the end of the game cuz I won't be
doing let's play anymore oh that's so
sad anyway I'm out timing myself thank
you all so much for watching except for
those people who I don't appreciate so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye